je suis donc chargeur germe la munition
dans le cadre principal
la culasse se referme mise à feu du
tireur la douille est éjectée le
chargeur récupère la munition encore
chaude et éjecte la munition en dehors
du char par les coutilles qui s'étaient
derrière moi ce que vous venez de voir
c'est le chargement du canon d'un
chercheur man datant de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale si cette démonstration
est possible c'est grâce à l'association
Versailles univers depuis 50 ans elle
restaure des véhicules de guerre pour
les ramener à la vie et les faire
défiler lors de commémoration pour nous
c'est vraiment important la conservation
du patrimoine et la continuité du devoir
de mémoire puisque ça nous permet de
sauver de la casse des véhicules c'est à
la fois notre passion et puis ça nous
rend très très fier quand on a des
vétérans qui ont connu le conflit qui
savent ce que c'est la guerre surtout
dans le contexte actuel et qui nous
laisse une marque indélébile sur notre
véhicule et qui reconnaissent que notre
travail sert à quelque chose mais une
contrainte vient de s'ajouter à leur
planning le projet du Grand Paris pour
construire l'une de ces nouvelles lignes
de métro le camp militaire perd une
partie de ses terrains et doit se
réorganiser notre contrainte que nous
avons actuellement donc c'est
effectivement c'est trouver des nouveaux
locaux dans volume capacité au minima de
3000 m² afin de préserver la collection
dans un premier temps et dans un
deuxième temps c'est effectivement avoir
donc une partie musée où on puisse mieux
accueillir le public l'association qui
compte 170 bénévoles à solliciter
plusieurs communes des Yvelines pour
trouver des locaux ils ont jusqu'au mois
d'août 2023 pour quitter les lieux